[Musica]
buonasera voglio raccontare una storia
un giorno d'estate di qualche anno fa a
milano prende un treno per la riviera
romagnola
milano marittima la tanto vituperata
milano marittima un luogo in cui il mio
bisnonno nel 1975 acquista una casa e
quella è la casa che è rimasta la stessa
per tutta la mia vita tra trasferimenti
traslochi e viaggi
torniamo a quel venerdì è stata in cui
alla fine di una settimana lavorativa
tra telefonate alla gli analisti
finanziari erano sullo studio di piani
triennali riesco a salire sul treno
della speranza verso la costa romagnola
e verso mia figlia che era lì al mare
con mia madre non mi fermo a cambiarmi
ma vado immediatamente sulla spiaggia e
senza scarpe con un borsone mi incammino
sulla passerella della spiaggia del
bagno del solito bagno e spero che
sappiate cosa è un bagno della costa
romagnola perché sono loro quei minuti e
lo staff in italia mi avvio verso gli
ombrelloni ma non riconosco gli effetti
dei miei famigliari non riconosco
l'ombrellone accaldata insofferente
mi guardo intorno e vedo una signora
vicino a me seduta su una seggiola da
spiaggia ingioiellata truccata che si
varia con un bellissimo ventaglio che mi
segue con lo sguardo attentamente allora
le chiedo se per caso abbia visto una
donna bionda di circa 60 anni con una
nipotina un'altra ragazza circa della
mia età con una bambina e lei mi dice ma
certo ti stavo guardando la tua signora
è andata a fare una passeggiata con sua
figlia e le nipotine verso cervia
poi adesso mettiti lì ad aspettare
quelle l'ombrellone vedrai che arrivano
io non riesco a dire altro che grazie
signora gentilissima adesso mi metto
seduta in effetti mi metto seduto ad
aspettare continuando a pensare a quella
parola
la tua signora ea chiedermi il
significato dopo venti minuti arriva mia
madre mia cognata mia figlia il nipotino
mia figlia mi salta al collo mia madre
mi bacia mi abbraccia mi chiede come sto
come è andato il viaggio e mia cognata
mi cede subito su rettino la signora ci
guarda con gli occhi sgranati come
quelli lungo fu cerca di attirare
l'attenzione del marito che però sta
facendo la settimana enigmistica sapete
com'è d'estate sulla riviera e non le
presta attenzione
lei cerca in giro una spalla del
testimone di quel fenomeno a cui appena
assistito io nel frattempo racconto
l'aneddoto le mie donne e dopo le risate
mia madre però mi dice certo che sei
tutta malmessa verona in casi molto
stanca adesso merito sul lettino che
prende un po di colorito perché sei
pallida per mia madre sono pallida e
questo il molto bello prima e dopo
questa scenetta ne ho vissute molte
altre più o meno divertenti più o meno
pesanti dagli anni 70 ad oggi è con voi
oggi lo posso dire sono sfinita io sono
italiana per metà e per metà
afroamericana
mi sono laureato in economia alla
bocconi o un master in corporate finance
ho lavorato per i quotidiani più
importanti del paese ma non sono
riuscita mai ad essere o quasi mai la
figlia di mia madre infatti ricordo che
la cartoleria la signora della
cartoleria dove andavamo quando facevamo
le medie un giorno si avvicina la mia
madre commossa dicendole quanto era
stata brava ad adottare non uno ma due
bambini stranieri di colore e alla
risposta di mia madre sono i miei
bambini
la signora s'è avvicinata in confidenza
dicendole o certo non gliel'ha detto
signora
ha fatto una cosa bellissima vivere tra
rappresentazione e realtà è molto
faticoso non sono mai riuscita ad essere
me io però nick costanza word
ma nessuno o centomila ma che non erano
io non erano me il sociologo dubois mi
ci terrebbe come un esempio di double
consciousness doppia consapevolezza ma
nel mio caso possiamo forse parlare di
malti paul consciousness perché
l'identità che mi sono state attribuite
sono veramente tantissime e oggi sono
qui oltre che esita a sfogarmi perché
voi mi aiutate ad evitare i nuovi ai
giovani a tre italiani la fatica di
dover affrontare queste questo
atteggiamento e per i quali il percorso
che li porta a acquisire ea ad avere le
possibilità e le opportunità non sia
caricato continuamente di questo peso
della rappresentazione in cui esiste uno
squilibrio tra nelle relazioni sociali
dovute a un'impreparazione forse ma che
si sostanzia in discriminazioni più o
meno consapevoli quando mi capita di
parlarne con gli amici conoscenti quello
che mi sento dire no veronica dai che è
successo ma è un caso non siamo mica
così noi siamo nel 2020
allora mi chiedo se ho vissuto e vivo in
un pianeta parallelo ancora il pari c'è
il pianeta della realtà e pianeta della
rappresentazione
so bene quanto sia facile parlare di un
problema quando non ci tocca da vicino
quando apparentemente lontano da noi
come per esempio ultimamente con gli
episodi che sono avvenuti negli stati
uniti che ovviamente conosco bene ho
visto indignazione gli amici giornalisti
gli scrittori anno
fatto lunghissimi artistico lì i titoli
dei giornali
il black light metal sarà diventata la
lotta di tutti le magliette con il pugno
chiuso indossate da chiunque
però non ho percepito e non percepisco
la stessa indignazione per quello che
succede qui oggi in italia non più di un
mese fa avvengono atti violenti che non
sono giustificabili ma quello che mi
preme di più è parlare di le sfumature
più leggere di discriminazione opere
dentemente più leggere di
discriminazione che sono estremamente
pesanti per chi ne è vittima
e sono altrettanto ingiustificabili e
ingiustificate le forme di razzismo e ho
tentato nella preparazione di questo
incontro a non citare mai la parola ma
non ci sono riuscita
sono tantissime vanno dalla violenza
alla discriminazione sul lavoro allo
squilibrio nei rapporti sociali e
influiscono e hanno influito su quel
percorso quel periodo in cui si cerca di
formare la propria identità in cui io
ero continuamente impegnata a rispondere
alla rappresentazione che veniva fatta
di me a rispondere a interrogatori a
dover guardare facce allibite e a
chiarire il malinteso malinteso che
veniva dal colore della mia pelle dai
miei tratti somatici il colore della
pelle ancora oggi in italia rappresenta
un qualcosa di sconosciuto e legittima
ancora un senso di superiorità e quindi
un atteggiamento che a volte può essere
meno di riguardo meno attento nei
confronti delle persone nere di
qualunque sfumature siano e allora mi
chiedo da cosa venga questo
atteggiamento da un passato colonialista
da degli stereotipi importati
dall'estero o da una mentalità ereditata
in america e molto in voga
una teoria che è quella della white
fragility quella fragilità dell'essere
bianchi quella in preparazione
i bianchi che viene dal non aver dovuto
affrontare non da non dover affrontare
le conseguenze negative del colore della
loro pelle e questo giustifica in
qualche modo la non preparazione e la
possibilità di incappare in
atteggiamenti discriminatori o anche
razzisti allora mi chiedo se questa
spiegazione valga anche per voi
anche qui in italia personalmente penso
che le buone intenzioni come quelle
della signora sulla spiaggia non
rappresenti noi non possono
rappresentare più una giustificazione
anzi credo rappresentino un in qualche
modo un aggravante del reato perché
portano con sé il rischio di non
assumersi mai la propria responsabilità
di non essere attivi di rimanere
indietro e di non partecipare quel
cambiamento che è inevitabile che già in
atto
qui a reggio emilia viviamo una realtà
evoluta è aperta in cui quel
multiculturalismo di cui tanto si parla
sembra una realtà consolidata ma nella
realtà la presenza nelle persone di
diversa origine le diverse nei diversi
ruoli della società non è una
quotidianità uno dei ragazzi più in
gamba che conosca avro italiano è
l'amministratore delegato di una
fondazione una società molto importante
in italia e mi raccontava la settimana
scorsa che essendo entrato poco in
questo ruolo
poco prima di una riunione
l'amministratore delegato di un'altra
società ha chiesto al suo collega in sua
assenza chi fosse e quando collega gli
ha risposto che a dama il mio capo
questo gli ha chiesto se stesse
scherzando
e non c'è solo ad hama la comunità di a
fra italiani e grande attiva e viva crea
cultura arte bellezza si incontra
discute crea consapevolezza ma
nonostante questo molti afro italiani
nati in italia non hanno il diritto
della cittadinanza per nascita e anche
coloro che sono nati in italia e hanno
avuto la cittadinanza vedono le loro
opportunità caricate di quella mentalità
di quell'atteggiamento non ancora
imbucato ultimamente peraltro se avete
notato sulle copertine dei giornali di
moda dei magazine di moda dei giornali
dei cartelloni pubblicitari degli spot
televisivo televisivi
adesso sono apparsi tantissimi ragazzi e
ragazze persone di colore nero
chiamatele come volete come se ci fosse
si fosse resi conto che adesso la
società è anche fatta dalle persone di
un colore diverso della pelle
il problema è che la rappresentazione
sempre la famosa rappresentazione non è
la realtà non è la vita quotidiano
l'esperienza fra italiana per noi la
conservazione nuova di vissuti per noi
italiani doc fanatici del rinascimento
ex imperialisti i nostalgici un po
comunisti un po cattolici familistica
ciaroni troppo pigri per la
multiculturalità ma abbastanza ambiziosi
quindi abbiamo nelle mani una grande
opportunità quella di cambiare la
narrazione del nostro paese e di
guardarlo in futuro con orgoglio e
contribuire al cambiamento della società
in cui viviamo per noi e per i nostri
figli figli da cui possiamo imparare
perché io li vedo muoversi con
naturalezza con disinvoltura in mezzo
alle diversità e le peculiarità di
ognuno con interesse e rispetto
e dallo stesso rispetto la stessa
leggerezza che ho vissuto io però solo
all'interno della mia famiglia in cui
non finché non sono stata obbligata non
ho dovuto dare un significato la
differenza di colore di pelle dei miei
genitori che peraltro sono qui da
qualche parte ho notato però la
differenza
nell'impostazione dell'educazione questo
certo si è anche un po l'accento buffo
di mio padre allora rappresentazione in
realtà vorrei farle coincidere perciò
che da voi la mano e della chiedo e
dicendo di questo
affrontiamo un problema non ami non
facciamo finta che il problema non
esiste solo perché non ci tocca è già un
grande passo e poi facciamo un altro
passo quando incontrate domani un'altra
me
uomo o donna che sia chiedete chi sei
così avrò almeno la possibilità di
rispondervi sono veronica costanza ward
sarebbe già un grande inizio conta su di
voi
grazie
[Applauso]